[Music]
on this monday night new urgency to
alberta's covid crisis why doctors are
pleading for a tight lockdown take some
action to help correct it and why the
premier is pushing back the future of
canada's relationship with china maybe
it's a sign that they are telling the
rest of the world look ostrich diplomacy
works and why washington's help was
critical to freeing the two michaels the
greens lose their leader it has been
the worst period in my life what's next
for the party plagued by infighting and
new clues on when humans first set foot
in north america this discovery is
pretty staggering how scientists are a
step closer to solving an ancient
mystery
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in alberta where the number of
people ending up in icu with covet 19
keeps growing and doctors are now
pleading for what they call a fire break
lockdown without it they say covet case
counts will keep rising and overwhelmed
hospital staff won't be able to maintain
a high standard of care premier jason
kenney though is resisting calls to
bring in tougher restrictions
icu capacity is now at 84 percent but
that includes the extra beds that have
already been added and the beds that
have opened up because people have died
without those extra beds the system
would be at 180 percent capacity the
vast majority of covid19 patients are
not fully vaccinated and the situation
could escalate as more people become
infected more than 10 percent of people
in alberta being tested for covid19
right now are testing positive heather
urex west spoke with one of those
unvaccinated patients about his
near-death experience and his regrets
she has our top story tonight
i was scared and i didn't know
what was going on like whether or not i
would live or not bernie cook is not
afraid to say he was wrong the 46 year
old underestimated the delta variant he
had held strong opinions against the
vaccine and because of that
he almost died i had a lot of reasons to
not vaccinate
one i'm a healthy guy
it's pneumonia
you know i was like
i could i can fight that boy was that
wrong
cook spent 11 days on a ventilator one
of hundreds of alberta covet patients in
intensive care
the system is overwhelmed and from the
inside cook could feel the stress and
strain all of us that were in
icu
and are flooding
the coved wards
we were only focused about ourselves we
weren't thinking about other people he
shares his regret now in the hopes that
others won't make his mistake but across
the province the sick keep coming it's
why alberta's former chief medical
officer of health is among those now
calling for more public health
restrictions getting people vaccinated
will help in the longer term but right
now he says alberta needs to shut down
places that allow indoor gatherings what
i fear is going to happen is that the
minister and premier will continue to
not take any action and we will continue
to lose 100 albertans a week but
speaking to chorus radio on sunday
alberta's premier was resistant to the
idea first of all that makes no sense
for the 80 percent of the population
that's vaccinated who are at much lower
levels of risk of transmission and
extremely lower level risks of
hospitalization
but secondly it's the roughly 20 of the
idle population who are unvaccinated who
are less likely to observe public health
measures alberta health services has not
yet started its critical care triage
protocol or transferred any patients out
of province for care but the only reason
this province has been able to manage
the growing demand is because so many
patients in icu's have died
donna
heather yorks west in calgary thank you
alberta like much of the country
requires proof of vaccination to go to
public places like restaurants it's up
to the businesses and their employees to
check people's vaccination status and
enforce the rules the vast majority of
times there's no problem but some staff
have faced threats and intimidation
jamie morocco reports
bill mafus and his staff just want to be
safe while serving up sandwiches
but during the first week enforcing
ontario's proof of vaccination program
he's already faced violence he
threatened to come back and fill up his
truck with bricks and destroy the place
the anchor he says has come in person
online and over the phone it's just
really unfair and and
to take out frustrations on these
on these young adults you know trying to
work outside calgary threats forced this
restaurant owner to temporarily close to
indoor diners entirely the comments that
were coming at us were significant
enough that we didn't feel confident or
safe in
opening the doors and having our staff
having to deal with this backlash
vaccine passports are a reality in most
provinces and already required in bc
alberta manitoba ontario and quebec
it does place you know extra extra
pressure on
small business that are already
feeling a lot of pressure without
intervention experts say businesses will
continue to bear the brunt of the bad
behavior these are government policies
and if people are unhappy they should be
raising that with their elected
politicians
at canada's busiest mall over the
weekend police arrested two people after
anti-vaccine protesters stormed the
eaton center ontario's minister of labor
and minister of health offered little
more than platitudes angry
confrontations where people can be hurt
is not all right you can't refuse in
service but it's happening near kingston
this coffee shop owner was berated after
asking a massless man to wait outside
what's wrong with this country i hope
you understand it
rattled and down a customer for some
following the rules means losing a sale
10 to 15 customers a day you know it
adds up taking a hit on profit while
just trying to do their part to protect
patrons jamie morocco global news
toronto
now to the relationship between china
and canada china maintains there's no
connection between the release of the
two michaels and the return of huawei
executive mong wang zhou much of the
world though considers it a case of
hostage diplomacy and as abigail beeman
reports how canada navigates its
relationship with china now is
complicated
canada should learn a lesson said
china's foreign ministry spokesperson
monday and not do dirty work for the u.s
blaming us and
it's like if they have not understood
anything or they feel so confident that
they want to they still want to put us
in our our place and there i think they
be maybe mistaken china insisting mong
won joe's case was one of political
persecution completely different from
those of michael kovrick and michael
spavor even though the two planes
carrying everyone home in opposite
directions were in the air at the same
time after more than a 1 000 day dispute
in the world's mind there's no doubt
that the two
arrests are related the white house also
bristled at the suggestion what happened
was a prisoner swap there is no link we
have an independent justice department
that made independent
decisions law enforcement decisions at
the same time we have made no secret
about our push to have them two michaels
released it's stranger and gets stranger
i understand why i don't agree with i
understand why
china doesn't want it to be a linkage
they're very sensitive to this charge of
hostage diplomacy
even if it fits which i think it does in
this instance a former canadian foreign
affairs minister says cover and spavor
would not be in their houses without the
white house canadians
should acknowledge and should be
grateful that president biden clearly
made
solving the mongol joe issue for china
conditional upon the release of the two
michaels there's no other way this would
have happened
had there not been linkage based on his
experience with the kevin garrett
negotiations another canadian formerly
imprisoned in china gisen jacques says
china could have put a big ask of canada
on the table a guarantee justin trudeau
would attend at the opening ceremonies
of the upcoming beijing olympics or even
approval of huawei's 5g network a
decision yet to be finalized they might
have been tempted to to ask that because
they know that we were eager to get the
two michaels back and they and they you
know but this would have been a real big
ask while experts may not agree on the
best approach going forward with china
they agree the most important thing for
now we are so happy now i am so
delighted to be back home with my family
and to be back in canada kovrick and
spavor are back
abigail beeman global news ottawa
i want to say that there is a struggle
that is going on for the soul of the
party
for those of you that want to see the
green party fulfill its its promise and
its values
then there is work to do
that is green party leader annemie paul
she says she doesn't have the heart to
stay on as leader after less than a year
at the helm she resigned today paul
became the first jewish woman and the
first black person to lead a major
federal political party but since the
day she took over from elizabeth may
she's been attacked by party insiders
and then lost her own seat in the
election the party didn't flourish under
her it barely survived as richard zusman
reports the question now is what's next
i just i just don't have the the heart
for it under attack from her own party
both before and during its unsuccessful
federal election campaign annemie paul
is out as green leader when you head
into an election being again under the
threat of a court process from your
party
it's going to be very hard to convince
people to to vote for your party the
results bear that out the greens going
from six and a half percent to the
popular vote nationally two years ago to
just 2.3 percent this time when i was
elected and put in this role i was
breaking a glass ceiling
what i didn't realize at the time is
that i was breaking a glass ceiling that
was going to fall on my head and leave a
lot of shards of glass that i was going
to have to crawl over the experience so
difficult she says she felt she could
not carry on for all of those people who
are disappointed for all of the
supporters who wrote and asked me to
please continue
please know that this was not easy it
has been extremely painful
it has been
the worst period in my life
there are now questions about what paul
short stint his leader canada's first
black federal party leader says about
larger problems of systemic racism in
canadian politics there's a number of
institutional blockages to
in expanding diversity and inclusion in
the house of commons the electoral
system is absolutely one
and for the greens questions about
relevance it dropped seats in new
brunswick and b.c adding only one new mp
in ontario now that virtually every
federal party leader has a climate plan
experts say the greens need to find a
new way to stand out beyond the
environment i hope there's a growing
consensus that we all need to be on
board in terms of climate change as a
critical issue so what does a green
party do former leader elizabeth may has
been criticized for not doing more to
support paul may turn down interview
requests monday leaving these words from
a speech to supporters election night on
where the party stands we do have to do
a lot of soul searching as a party as to
where the preparations for the election
fell far so far short there's no
timeline for when a new leader for the
greens will be chosen richard lisman
global news victoria
a rescue operation is underway near
sudbury ontario for 39 miners trapped
underground since yesterday afternoon
they are deep inside a shaft of the vale
totten mine a copper and nickel
operation just west of sudbury the
company says the workers became trapped
after an incident in the shaft sunday
afternoon the company says the 39 miners
are at refuge stations and are safe it's
hoped they'll reach the surface tonight
using a ladder system new york's mandate
to vaccinate coming up the healthcare
workers who would rather give up their
jobs than get the jab plus the verdict
is in singer r kelly learns his fate
u.s president joe biden got a covit 19
booster shot today american regulators
recommend a booster of the pfizer
vaccine for anyone over age 65 and for
adults who are at increased risk biden
who is 78 qualified because he received
his second pfizer vaccine more than six
months ago the u.s has more vaccine
doses than any country in the world yet
uptake has stalled and the u.s has
fallen far behind the rest of the
western world in administering covid
vaccines according to johns hopkins
university less than 56 percent of
americans are fully vaccinated the us
now ranks 42nd in the world and as
jackson proskow reports strategies to
convince the holdouts don't seem to be
working
decision day in new york where health
care workers faced a choice get
vaccinated or lose their jobs nurse
diana marciano is one of the holdouts
you know i'm scared because they're like
threatening my livelihood with doctors
and nurses already stretched thin losing
just a few workers could tip some
hospitals into crisis very nervous my
co-workers and i can't stop talking
about how nervous we are the state's
governor has suggested deploying the
national guard to deal with the
potential staffing shortage but isn't
backing down i don't know about you but
i'm sick and tired of talking about
covet controversial as they may be
mandates have proven highly effective
from the u.s military to private
companies like united airlines which
reports 98 percent of staff have now
taken the jab the vaccine mandate
pushback that we're getting seems to
really follow the lines of the pushback
that we've gotten all along about many
of the mitigation strategies to try to
prevent and control kobit 19.
still it's too little too late to blunt
the current surge which is killing an
average of 2 000 americans every single
day
that distinct minority is causing an
awful lot of us
a lot of damage for the rest of the
country that has given more ammunition
to mandate backers who argue the cost of
not requiring immunization has proven to
be far too high the u.s remains the
global outlier in the pandemic and is
still responsible for nearly a quarter
of the new covid cases recorded every
single day on the planet at the same
time this country has thrown out more
than 15 million doses of vaccine since
march that have gone unwanted and
expired on shelves
donna
all right jackson in washington thanks
musician r kelly has been convicted of
racketeering and sex trafficking a new
york jury found the r b singer guilty on
all counts kelly was convicted of luring
women and underage girls into his
entourage for sexual purposes a scheme
that dates back to the 1990s the 54 year
old faces trials in two other states
also on sex related charges
germany's election is over but the
results are unclear ahead who might take
over from angela merkel
residents on the eastern shore of la
palma spain are being ordered to lock
down as lava gushes towards the atlantic
ocean the lava which reaches
temperatures of 1200 degrees celsius
could cause explosions and release toxic
gases when it hits the water scientists
think the volcanic activity is starting
to slow it's no longer releasing large
clouds of ash and molten rock but more
than 500 buildings have been buried in
lava and more than 6 000 people have
been displaced
there is a political upheaval in germany
tonight the center-left social democrats
narrowly defeated outgoing chancellor
angela merkel's party in yesterday's
election it's not clear who will govern
though coalition negotiations are now
underway as redmond shannon reports the
election is over and now the hard part
for europe's biggest economy begins
angela merkel is taking a back seat as
the haggling to succeed her begins
her current government partners the
center-left social democrats leapfrogged
her conservative christian democrats in
sunday's election their candidate is
merkel's steady-handed vice chancellor
olaf schultz we will be very fast and
getting a result for this government and
it should be before christmas if
possible but with the two parties so
close christian democrat candidate armin
laschette says he has the right to try
to form a government too even after
their historically low results but it's
the green party and the pro-business
free democrats who are said to be king
makers they could choose lash it for a
three-party black green yellow or
jamaica coalition or team up with
schultz for a so-called traffic light
coalition analysts say the latter is
more likely given germany's poor record
on emissions activists who also support
the green party they feel you know the
the conservatives had their chance at
doing something about climate change
for decades now and they haven't done so
lashed leadership credentials took a hit
when he was seen laughing during a visit
to the scene of the deadly floods in
western germany some of his colleagues
say he needs to quit for the party's
sake if the city were to change horse
now after this election this would be
unprecedented but not unthinkable
then there may be a new opening but only
after the traffic light negotiations
previous coalition negotiations between
two parties have taken months so don't
be surprised if merkel is still
caretaker chancellor come 2022 redmond
shannon global news london
in britain fuel pumps are running dry
because of a shortage of truck drivers
and a weekend of panicked gas buying
[Music]
people lined up for hours to fill their
cars the petrol retailers association
says about two-thirds of its members
have run out of gas the u.k has lost as
many as a hundred thousand truckers
because of an aging workforce and an
exodus of foreign workers after britain
left the european union
fossil footprints next the ancient
tracks that could have big implications
for human history
we humans certainly leave our mark on
the planet and sometimes even our
footsteps can tell a tale scientists in
new mexico have found tracks left behind
by prehistoric pedestrians people who
lived alongside mammoths and walked the
edges of a vanished ice age lake more
than 20 thousand years ago eric sorenson
explains the big implications for human
history
the vast and dry gypsum landscape in
what is now new mexico was once a giant
lake archaeologists began digging
through the layers of sediment laid down
over tens of thousands of years and then
clear as day they came upon this
fossilized human footprints
carbon dating of ancient seeds found
among the footprints suggested a time
long before it was thought possible more
testing of more layers confirmed the
footprints were children walking by an
ancient lake almost 10 000 years before
we thought humans had arrived in north
america radiocarbon dating with a very
high degree of certainty
and
we were astounded at just how old they
turned out to be in africa skulls of
homo sapiens date earlier than 100 000
years ago from there great migrations
began first through the middle east to
south asia and later to australia into
europe 40 to 50 000 years ago more
recently humans crossed over what was
then a land bridge that existed between
siberia and north america it was
believed they came only after the
glaciers of the last ice age had begun
to recede around 13 000 years ago the
new footprint suggests humans came
before the ice blocked migration and
came to the southwestern u.s up to 23
000 years ago
this discovery
is pretty pretty staggering because it
says people were actually here before
those routes closed up it's believed the
early humans in north america would have
coexisted with mastodons and other
primitive species they may well have
been the forebears of the indigenous
people in the americas and the study
suggests an early society existed here
for at least 2 000 years you can just
kind of picture the kids
it's like you know oh let's let's go
down play by the lake uh or their
parents say go get some water you know
it's just like step step step step step
these little glimpses of of activity and
interaction over time are just just
fascinating to me scientists say future
research should focus on even older
undisturbed surfaces where there may be
earlier evidence of humans we didn't
realize were already here eric sorensen
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is moraine lake in banff national
park we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
you